nouvelle affaire ségolène royal la
ministre déléguée à l'enseignement
scolaire a décidé de relancer la
campagne de lutte contre le racket dans
les collèges la violence à l'origine de
nombreux mouvements de grève dans les
établissements ces jours ci comme à
montpellier à roubaix ou encore à
vénissieux dans la banlieue lyonnaise où
cet après midi parents et enseignants
ont manifesté leur exaspération lorraine
berrou quatre bus bondés venu de la
banlieue jusqu'à la préfecture de lyon
parents d'élèves et enseignants excédés
ont revendiqué le droit à la sécurité de
leurs enfants un droit simple qu'ils
estiment de plus en plus bafoués nous
colle ya des vitres cassées ya des
méchants et diani contient les écoles on
ne veut pas devenir un ghetto nos
enfants sont là aussi pour le dire ils
veulent continuer à venir à l'école
correctement comme n'importe quel enfant
de france montpellier cet après-midi
vingt-quatre heures après la visite de
ségolène royal les enseignants restent
mobilisés et continue la grève au
collège des aiguerelles ici les
promesses ministérielles de lendemains
meilleurs n'ont pas convaincu bien
préparé leur coup
dans ce sens si les intéressait c'est
d'éteindre le conflit ici mais en aucun
cas vraiment de trouver les solutions
pour résoudre le problème qui est le
nôtre actuellement et qui n'est pas
simplement le problème des aiguerelles
ce problème bien sûr c'est celui de la
violence agressions raquette
intimidations vol ou simple menace les
jeunes aussi réclament une pause
nous venons collège pour apprendre et
non poursuivies ré assister à la
violence qui est quotidienne où vous
remercions de bien vouloir tenir compte
du point de vue des élèves qui se
sentent entièrement concernés par cette
action tenir compte de leurs paroles
c'était l'objectif affiché du ministère
lorsqu'il a créé il ya un peu plus d'un
an le numéro vert sos violences en
semaine seulement et jusqu'à 18 heures
ces deux étudiantes s'y attellent
bénévoles en cette période de crise
elles font face à 70 appels par jour de
leur propre aveu des violences mineurs
les vrais cas d'agression sont cachés
par peur de représailles
un aveu qu'elle ne feront pas face à la
caméra